today we're in the northern Danish city
of Aarhus brother is gay a side street
in the city centre is home to a
restaurant that's very popular with the
locals substance has only a few tables
so it's best to make a reservation chef
rene incident his team specialize in
danish cuisine he places great value in
featuring locally sourced produce in his
dishes
I like the most about cooking is to take
all these different kinds of raw
material things and watch them become
small elements in in dishes and each and
every one of them in place a different
part that's definitely what I enjoy the
most about isn't creating a thing I'm a
really raw thing while the team is
preparing a new dessert gooseberries
with pumpkin seeds and oak ice cream
Renee ensem goes to the forest to
collect Ramson Ramson is related to
onions chives and garlic that's why it's
popular as a condiment for sauces and
dips or just as a side dish
I picked the remnants because I want to
put the flavor in our dishes because the
the flavors and the smell is so it's
very classic for for all those or even
towns in this season in the spring time
so we want to give that feeling to our
guests today Renee Anson will use the
fresh Ramson to season a starter made up
of smoked haddock besides Ramson he also
needs cress radishes cucumbers and
pickled onions all the ingredients are
very classic Danish most of them are
used in Smallville smoke spread as well
both the smoked fish and the mayonnaise
and the radishes we try to do it a bit
different with the evil mayonnaise first
he cuts the fish into small pieces
instead of havoc you can also use other
smoked fish Renee Henson then scoops out
little cucumber balls which he prefers
to cucumber slices then he grates the
radishes and places them in cold water
to keep them fresh the pickled onions
are halved and the chef's next step is
to chop the Ramson and mix it with olive
oil in a blender for about five minutes
the remsen oil will serve as the base
for an herbal mayonnaise
the thing that's most important for me
in this kitchen is that all the all
ingredients we use is that they taste of
what they are we don't we don't try to
make a cucumber taste like a rabbit but
we like the cleanness of the products
now he prepares his starter courses to
add a crunchy note Renee inson garnishes
the plate with malt crackers
so here you go smoked haddock with the
cucumber ransoms and crunchy moles
co-opt Renee Hansen says greeting his
customers personally is an important
part of his work